ladies and gentlemen please give a big
welcome to the president of the Academy
of Motion Picture Arts and Sciences Miss
Cheryl Boone Isaacs and the chairman of
the scientific and technical awards main
committee and Academy governor
representing the visual effects frames
mr. Richard Edlund
good evening everyone and welcome to the
87th Academy Awards scientific and
technical Awards thank you for all the
work you've jhanas president to honor
many science and technology initiatives
and the tremendous achievements of
tonight's honorees thank you Richard
no problem and thank you for all your
efforts and dedication as a governor and
as the chair of the scientific and
technical awards main committee I'm
really thrilled to be back at our
favorite venue the Beverly Wilshire here
and to be celebrating extraordinary
worked as brought everyone here tonight
on behalf of the scientific and
technical awards main committee I'd like
to congratulate all of our honorees we
would also like to it we would also like
to acknowledge all the Academy governors
who are here tonight would you all
please stand
and I would also like to thank our
Academy staff a wonderful group of
professionals without whom none of this
would be possible
I want to acknowledge the Academy
Science and Technology Council which
continues to play a leading role in the
important technological issues facing
our industry in the past year alone the
council has delivered a number of tools
and resources to the industry to name a
few
the academy color predictor ipad app
which helps filmmakers understand the
interaction of new solid-state lighting
and technical cameras in cinematography
and test footage entitled the affair for
the industry to use as it learns about
next-generation cinema technologies such
as high frame rate and high dynamic
range perhaps the most exciting news is
the release of the academy color
encoding system also known as aces
version 1.0
which provides much-needed
infrastructure and production standards
for color management image interchange
and archiving many of you here tonight
have contributed to the development of
aces and now that this work is done the
Academy is collaborating with all of our
industry partners on a comprehensive
marketing and education program to
enable the rapid and widespread adoption
of aces as the production and archiving
standard from motion pictures
the Academy from its earliest days has
been committed to recognizing
individuals who have made some ager
contributions to science and technology
and cinema they wouldn't be able to make
movies without us to recognize your
accomplishments and celebrate the
amazing innovations you've brought to
the industry and to which have
transformed the way that audiences
around the world have experienced this
cinema thank you for setting such an
extraordinary example for our industry
this is your night
we have an exciting evening ahead so
welcome back and we'll be back with the
show after a short break
enjoy